today's video is brought to you by keeps
the online subscription service that
helps men keep the hair that they have
more on them in just a bit in 1960 an
American novel appeared from a then
unknown writer title To Kill a
Mockingbird the novel told its story
through the voice of a woman describing
her childhood as a young girl called
Scout Jane Louise she described
her adventures with her elder brother
Gem and oh their summer visitor Dil
Harris Scout's mother died before the
events of the novel and she and her
brother are raised by their lawyer
father Atticus Finch and housekeeper and
cook Calpurnia a black woman of long
employment by the finches it became an
immediate bestseller won the 1961
Pulitzer Prize for literature and was
adapted into a 1962 Motion Picture which
gained eight Oscar nominations including
for best picture though it lost in that
category to Lawrence of Arabia it won
awards for best screenplay and best
actor Gregory Peck over the ensuing
decades To Kill a Mockingbird and
widespread Acclaim it became a required
reading in American schools its themes
of racial Injustice and relationships
widely debated and discussed this writer
Harper Lee became nearly a recluse
ignoring requests for interviews and
appearances a writing little and
avoiding the Limelight not until 2015
did she publish another novel go set a
Watchman which had originally been
written as part of what became To Kill a
Mockingbird even the publicity over that
event and the public outcry regarding
what she had done with some of her
characters did not bring her into public
view she alternator between living
quietly in New York City and Monroeville
in Alabama the necessary publicity tours
and appearances which followed the
release of killer Mockingbird did not
sit well with Lee and despite the urging
of friends and family she disregarded
please to publish another book yet her
life was active and long and she
remained a force in the literary world
for decades not for years did it become
evident that her first novel had been
largely autobiographical and the events
that she related as fictional had in
fact shaped her life beginning when she
was a six-year-old girl in the 1930s in
Alabama the characters she created and
the adventures they faced became
enduring symbols of American literature
bringingly lasting Fame though her
subsequent life left her shroud three
foreign
ER with the last name of Lee naturally
claimed to be related to Robert E Lee in
the early 20th century in the case of
Nelly Harper Lee that claim was accurate
through her father a Marta Coleman Lee a
newspaper editor attorney at law and
state legislature the young Nelly was a
member of the famed Lee family she was
the fourth of four children with her
older brother Edwin the only one of her
siblings close enough to her age to play
together as children Nelly the name she
used throughout her life was born on
April 28 1926 in Monroeville Alabama
where she spent her childhood at an
early age she made friends with a yearly
visitor to Monroeville who came to town
to spend the Summers with relatives and
live next door Nelly later immortalized
her childhood friend as the character
Dil Harris a small somewhat effeminate
boy uninterested and ill-equipped for
the Rough and Tumble play of other
boys's age his real name was Truman
Capote Neil was a tomboy as a young girl
preferring the company of her brother
and Dill to that of other girls her age
she also loved to read Millie was taught
to read by her father and before she
entered first grade she a red newspaper
as daily discussing their content with
her father she also discussed his legal
Affairs and trials as they appeared in
the newspaper one such trial later
served as an inspiration for events
described into killer Mockingbird the
south of Lee's childhood was the
segregated racially divided region of
Jim Crow laws and beliefs Monroeville
was a small town with little industry
and little hard money the great
depression's adverse effects were deeply
felt children played a barefo for the
most part since shoes were expensive and
had to be saved to school and church
children played games their older
siblings had taught them or created
their own schools churches restaurants
other businesses and playgrounds were
segregated the Ku Klux Klan remained a
force in Alabama in the 1930s a fact
nearly alluded to in a novel goat had a
Watchman out of which To Kill a
Mockingbird was formed racial
segregation and race-hating language was
just a daily fact of life another fact
of life was biting poverty the Lee
family was well fed the master owned the
house in which Nelly and her siblings
were raised and his legal work was
steady yet many of his clients were
unable to pay him cash substituting
barter or services in return for his
legal work it was another characteristic
nearly later attributed to Atticus Fitch
along or with descriptions of fictional
Maycomb and it's denizens in To Kill a
Mockingbird Nelly completed a high
school education in 1944 and attended an
all-female College in Montgomery Alabama
for a year she then entered the
University of Alabama where she wrote
for the student newspaper into Humor
Magazine in 1948 she attended a summer
program at Oxford University paid for by
her father in the hope that it would
stimulate her interest in pursuing the
law The Hope proved to be in vain Nelly
never finished her law degree and Upon
returning to America she decided to move
to New York City hoping to make a living
as a writer so hello everybody today I
want to talk to you about something very
very serious hair loss something I know
a lot about but don't worry I've got a
solution for you that came too late for
me it's called keeps and I wish I had
discovered it sooner because keeps is an
online subscription service that helps
you keep the hair that you have that's
right you can get expert recommended
hair loss treatments delivered straight
to your door and the best part it's
affordable keeps is typically half the
cost of Pharmacy prices and all the
treatment plans are personalized and
recommended by a licensed medical
provider and if you need help or support
keeps have you covered 24 7 with expert
support each treatment plan comes with a
full year of unlimited messaging so you
can connect with your medical provider
about anything anytime plus keeps has an
award-winning all-natural thickening
shampoo and conditioner system
everything your hair needs delivered
straight to your door don't be like me
take care of your hair today so what are
you waiting for hair loss stops with
keeps to get a special offer go to
keeps.com biographics or click the link
in the description below that's keps.com
biographics and now today's video
needing to make a living nearly began
working in a bookstore before landing a
better paying job as an airline agent
she also renewed her childhood
friendship with Truman Capote the
preceding year Capote had published
other voices other rooms establishing
himself as a leader of the literary
Community one of his characters in the
semi-autobiographical novel is Idabel
Tompkins a southern tomboy of
cantankerous temperament based Loosely
on Nelly Harper Lee Lee herself wrote
several stories for magazine publication
while at the same time working on a
novel she titled go set the Watchman the
novel took years to write in December
1956 several of her friends gave Lee a
gift of one year's salary enabling her
to concentrate on writing full-time Lee
delivered goat at her Watchman to her
agent in 1957 who sent it to several
Publishers only one Lippincott company
showed any interest at Lippincott her
work was reviewed by Theresa Von hahoff
Tori also known professionally as Tay
hohoff Harve did not consider the work
ready for publication and she began a
lengthsly relationship wisley reworking
the novel The editorial process
consisted of multiple rewrites as
half-off LED Lee to shape the story into
what would become To Kill a Mockingbird
the lengthy process frustratedly who at
one point threw the manuscript out of a
window when she subsequently informed
her half over the phone the editor
demanded she retrieve the pages
[Music]
in late 1959 Capote found a brief
article in the New York Times describing
the murder of the Clutter family in
Holcomb Kansas Capote traveled to campus
to investigate the murders wisely taking
Lee with him having been brought up in a
small town herself Lee was able to open
doors and establish trust from those who
otherwise treated the flamboyant Capote
with suspicion it was nearly six years
between that first trip to Kansas and
the appearance of In Cold Blood which
Capote labored as a new genre the
non-fiction novel kapoto serialized the
story of In Cold Blood in the New York
Magazine before it was published in book
form though he dedicated it in part to
Harper Lee he did not acknowledge her
contribution to the work which included
detailed notes that she kept during many
of the interviews that the two conducted
in Holcomb before In Cold Blood appeared
in print Harper Lee was a famous author
in her own right professional Jealousy
on the part of karate and his seeming
dismissal of Lee's contributions to his
non-fiction novel created tensions
between the two long time friends
To Kill a Mockingbird was published by
Lippincott in July 1960. critics almost
unanimously hailed the work and it
became an overnight success shaped by
years of hard work rewrites and lengthy
discussions between half and Lee there
was also speculation over whether Capote
had contributed to the writing of Lee's
book this led to rumors that persisted
for decades that Capote had authored the
book its entirety fed in part by Harper
Lee not publishing another work
publication brought with it pressures
only for public appearances interviews
for print radio and television and other
demands on her time when a Horton foot
was hard to write the screenplay for the
film based on a novel Lee consulted with
him as well as with actor Gregory Peck
who portrayed Atticus Finch Peck and his
family remained friends with Lee for the
rest of their lives when Universal
re-released the film to kill a marking
bird on DVD in 2005. Lee contributed to
the liner notes referring to Gregory
Peck she wrote The Years told me his
secret when he played Atticus Finch he
had played himself in 1961 killamokin
bird on the Pulitzer Prize an award
which further strained her long
friendship with Truman Capote capote's
jealousy was not assuaged when a word of
her involvement within Cold Blood
emerged which included some rumors that
she had assisted in writing the book Lee
retreated from the Limelight avoiding
the social scene in New York in which
Capote thrived pressure on her to
produce another novel simply drove her
to increase her reclusiveness supported
by her editor at Lippincott who helped
Shield her from the requests for
interviews and for stories about her
private life she maintained a New York
address for decades on East 82nd Street
in Manhattan near capote's home but she
also traveled frequently to Monroeville
and other destinations
[Music]
as the 1960s went on the civil rights
movement and increased awareness of the
racial issues in the South helped to
Kill a Mockingbird relevant in some
schools it became mandatory reading in
others it became controversial in 1964
Harper Lee stopped answering any
questions about the book regardless of
how they were raised she also refused to
add an introduction to the book as
subsequent editions were printed a
position she maintained for the rest of
her life when President Lyndon Johnson
appointed Harper Lee to the National
Council on the Arts in 1965. she
remained largely silent she was not
silent when libraries scoreboards and
other entities threatened to remove her
book from shelves and curricula though
in 1966 a Richmond Virginia school board
determined to Kill a Mockingbird was an
example of immoral literature happily
sent the board a signed letter in which
she defended her work and described the
board's reasoning as orwellian quote
surely it is plain to the simplest
intelligence that To Kill a Mockingbird
spells out in words of seldom more than
two syllables a code of honor and
conduct Christian in its ethic that is
the heritage of all Southerners to hear
that the novelism moral has made me
count the years between now and 1984 for
I've yet to come across a better example
of doublethink throughout the decades
following its publication To Kill a
Mockingbird struggled with those who
would censor it
foreign
in the 1970s Harper Lee returned to
Monroeville she began researching and
drafting a new book tentatively titled
the Reverend based on a murder trial
this time of a serial killer she worked
on it for a time before setting it aside
unfinished in Alabama she socialized
with family and friends enjoyed playing
golf and continued to avoid reporters
and other writers who wanted to
interview her in some ways she was far
from reclusive she simply wanted much
like Greta Garbo to be left alone her
lifelong fear of flying better to travel
from Monroeville by train when
recognized she accommodated those asking
for autograph sometimes with a brief
complaint over the rudeness of the
request but she signed according to her
relatives and friends in Monroeville she
worked on the Reverend for nearly a
decade still examining the records and
reports concerning the case in the late
1980s whether she planned the work as a
non-fiction novel in the same manner as
in Cold Blood or not is unknown since
she never finished it and the
manuscript's whereabouts are Unknown by
the 1990s she had abandoned the project
in 1965 she published an article in
McCall's titled when children discover
America the 1985 of Anthology clearings
in the thicket included an article she
had written and presented two years
earlier romance and high adventure in
2006 she published an open letter to
Oprah Winfrey which appeared in oh the
Oprah Magazine other than that she
remained mostly silent in Monroeville
she found a community ready and willing
to about her efforts to protect her
privacy family and friends would speak
of her to reporters or researchers but
not regarding her opinions or her work
monrova which had served as the model
for the fictional Maycomb in a novel
came to celebrate the book without
bothering its author tourism centered on
the town's role and Kill a Mockingbird
became a significant source of income
for the town the the supported the
tourism nor participated in it by the
1990s the tourist industry in
Monroeville included plays performed in
the county courthouse gift shops and
annual celebrations when the town became
too crowded and visitors demands for Aur
autograph two pressing Lee escaped to
New York where she was for the most part
Anonymous in Monroeville though there
were friends and family who tried to
Shield Lee from prying eyes there were
also those who tried to exploit both her
nearness and her literary claim on
several occasions Lee was forced to
either take or threaten to take legal
action her sister Alice served as a
lawyer having taken over the father's
firm after his death in 1962. for the
latter years of the 20th century the
sisters lived together in a Monroeville
house though Lee was reclusive she was
far from a Hermit going out for coffee
at various local businesses engaging in
Long conversations with friends and
neighbors though she avoided organized
events she grew to detest the
commercialization of Mockingbird and the
tourist business which blossomed around
town when a gift shop near the
courthouse which had served as the model
for the courthouse in the film Burge and
To Kill a Mockingbird announced a book
for sale titled caperna's cookbook Lee
had Alice threatened legal action
Calpurnia was the name of the Finch's
maid the book was ultimately withdrawn
there were other legal actions stemming
from former literary agents machinations
over copyrights and royalties legal work
kept Lee sister Alice busy in her law
office when some of the legal issues
drew the attention of reporters from the
northern press Alice handled them
continuing to jealously guard police
privacy
[Music]
at the beginning of the 21st century To
Kill a Mockingbird retained its
long-standing popularity and continued
to be the focal point of controversy
most of the controversy came from groups
to crying the book as immoral others
complained of its depiction of racism in
the Jim Crow South calls to remove it
from schools and libraries continued and
in fact continued to the present day yet
Lee continued to receive accolades
honoring her work with some citing the
book as ranking among the greatest of
American literature she also was honored
for a work much of which was in private
in supporting the humanities and
cultural advancement in 2002 Lee was
given the Alabama Humanities Award in
2005 the Birmingham pledge Foundation
founded to support the values described
in the Birmingham pledge intended to
ensure equality and respect among all
people gave her their Lifetime
Achievement Award she was awarded the
presidential medal of freedom America's
higher civilian award by President
George W bush in 2007 honored for her
contributions to literature and she
received the 2010 National medal of Arts
awarded to her in a ceremony the
following year by President Barack Obama
by then Nelly was living in Monroeville
in an assisted living facility dealing
with declining Health as a result of a
stroke that she suffered in 2007. she
received visitors from her sisters and
from close friends and trusted Library
Associates always guarded closely by
Alice who likely had never married
reports of her declining Health appeared
in newspapers and magazine articles from
time to time though there was no longer
any speculation over when or if Harper
Lee would produce another book in 2015
it seemed that To Kill a Mockingbird
would remain her Legacy then a
publishing thunderstorm struck
foreign
the literary world was shocked by an
announcement that a lost manuscript
written by Harper Lee a sequel to To
Kill a Mockingbird had been discovered
in a safe deposit box according to
published reports the still living Lee
had approved it for publication under
the title go set a Watchman subsequent
reports which nonetheless preceded
publication of the new novel indicated
it had been discovered as early as 2011.
speculation amongst Lee's fans and
friends as well as in literary circles a
led to controversy Lee had by then been
living in an assisted care facility for
many years and the depth of her
involvement in the decision to publish
the book became a matter of debate when
the novel itself appeared in print the
controversy spread to the content of the
story it told set 20 years after the
events in Mockingbird gosetter Watchman
revealed Atticus Finch to be a star
segregationist a believer in white
supremacy and an active member of the Ku
Klux Klan in 1950s make whom Alabama
critics quickly attacked the book it was
described as an unedited first draft of
Mockingbird rather than a sequel with
the two novels sharing multiple passages
and scenes in some cases verbatim Lee's
involvement with the publication of
Watchmen also became a point of
controversy she remained unavailable for
comment statement in her name were
issued by her attorneys or agents her
sister Alice died in 2014 the year
preceding the discovery of the Lost
manuscript by the time Watchmen had been
announced Lee was confined to a
wheelchair legally blind yet there were
some including those who claimed to be
close to the writer who asserted she was
lucid in control of her Affairs and had
been active in the preparation of goat
and a Watchman for publication
on February the 19th 2016 at the age of
89 and with go set a Watchman still the
subject of controversy Nelly Harper Lee
passed away in Monroeville according to
news reports she died peacefully in her
sleep her funeral was held the next day
in Monroeville and like most of her life
it was conducted privately she was
buried alongside her sister Alice in a
family plot which also contained the
graves of her father and mother despite
the private nature of the services her
passing always noted by media Outlets
across the English-speaking world World
following her death in New York Times
sued to have her will unsealed in
Probate Court in compliance with Alabama
Law the document provided that Lee's
literary assets including copyrights as
well as most of her other assets be
transferred to a trust established in
2011 the same year some alleged go set a
Watchman was found one of the two
Trustees for what was designated the
Mockingbird trust was Tonya Carter Lee's
attorney of record at the time of her
death as well as the discoverer of the
manuscript of goat Watchman her will
also distributed some of her remaining
estate to a niece and three nephews
Tonya Carter was named executor of the
estate thus in death as in life Lee's
private life including her relationships
with family and friends remained closely
guarded by the author herself and those
she selected to be the Watchman at her
Gates whether other undiscovered
manuscripts of her work remain there
have been hints and are awaiting the
proper time to be exposed to the light
of day is unknown it is still relatively
easy to find websites which describe her
as having written just one novel
ignoring the existence of goset to
Watchmen it's probably safe to assume
that if another worker emerges it will
be matched with unbridled enthusiasm by
fandom To Kill a Mockingbird eager to
curl up with another work by The elusive
Harper Lee